everyone loves a road trip right you
pack up the car set the destination and
drive across a bunch of Eastern Bloc
countries with your uncle and a bucket
of water in a car that seems to be
falling apart of the hinges part Oregon
Trail parsh mechanic simulator part
papers please this game called jalopy
really is something unique I've
certainly never played anything like it
and it's available right now on early
access for a mere twelve dollars but is
it worth all the travel are you better
off just staying at home let's find out
Jelani is a game where you nurse a four
wheeled banger across a number of
countries you stay in hotels by parts
Phillipa petrol and listen to your uncle
wax lyrical about the good old days in
the fall of socialism but it's not about
getting to your destination fast
it's about getting there in one piece
you see jalopy is a term of endearment
for a car that's let's say past its best
and yours is a like a 601 deluxe a car a
car made of parts parts that can break
parts the need to be repaired or
replaced parts that need to be taken
care of for instance the Leica has a
two-stroke engine meaning you got to
make sure there's at least some oil in
there or it's gonna run less efficiently
and get damaged more quickly but it's
not all about the mechanics there's an
element of surgeon simulator in here too
this car doesn't drive itself if you
want to pop the hood you gotta pull its
lever you're not required to change
gears or indicate with your blinkers but
you can't expect to do everything else
from turning on the ignition to flicking
on your lights and wipers using the
handbrake even rolling down the window
to hand border guards your passport
jalopy is charming as hell and all these
interactions let in spirit to a game it
doesn't say much but says what it does
rather well for instance you can buy
supplies in petrol at any gas station
you pass but the first time I did I
couldn't find my wallet to pay the lady
so I had to run back and search the
whole car of course it was in the bloody
glove compartment you've also got a
trunk full of here to help you along the
way but it works like Resident Evil's
grid system meaning it has limited space
I mean it's probably nice to have a
bucket of water so you can clean off all
the mud on your windshield but that
takes up a lot of room this inventory
management puzzle is one area where the
games early
rough edges are most apparent but in a
game center drain trying to get
something that's broken to work properly
I found myself surprisingly forgiving of
these nails though less so with some of
the behaviors of the AI drivers oh and
my uncle decided to find a faster way to
the other side of the continent saving
and quitting doesn't actually save your
progress but it will reload you back at
the last hotel you checked into which is
just as well because even in this early
version the further you get the more
challenging the gameplay becomes it all
seems rosy on your trip until you
realize you forgot to pop some oil in
the engine and it's eating itself alive
it's a very good sign for a game when
even losing is fun and even when you
find yourself on the wrong side of a bad
decision staring at a broken bridge
miles from anywhere with no fuel in the
rain while the Sun is setting you can't
help but laugh like a bangle car it's
challenging but jalopy has a wonderful
sense of charm it wears its inspiration
on its sleeves there are shades of
eightydaze surgeon sim papers please
among others but jalopy is perhaps above
anything else one of the most unique
games I've played this year if you're
interested jalopy is rough but ready to
play right now on Steam for a very
reasonable $12